[Música]
economía en directo américa me acompaña
en el estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de ese
pesimismo que hay en los mercados a la
espera de los tipos de interés que
puedan ser anunciados en eeuu bueno es
que será este miércoles precisamente
cuando la reserva federal de ese país
anunció por fin una nueva subida de los
tipos de interés que se traducen
básicamente en el valor que le ponen al
dinero los analistas apuntan a una
subida del 0,75 por ciento como
respuesta al dato de la inflación en ese
país del viernes que llegó al 8,6 por
ciento anual en mayo la cifra más alta
en 40 años desde su inicio la fed
propuso subir los tipos de interés
gradualmente en incrementos en medio
punto pero periódicos como the water
journal no descartan un aumento agresivo
de 0.75 puntos la reserva federal subió
los tipos por primera vez desde 2018 en
marzo pasado en 0.25 puntos la siguiente
fue en mayo de 0.5 puntos representantes
de la fed dijeron en varias ocasiones
que subida de medio punto estaban sobre
la mesa pero un incremento del 0.75 es
algo que hasta ahora no estaba en el
debate escuchemos qué dicen los
analistas sobre esta decisión que tiene
a los mercados
bueno el presidente de la reserva
federal power dijo que los 75 puntos
básicos no estaban sobre la mesa en la
última reunión de la reserva federal
pero síndico que siempre están
monitoreando los datos y que responderán
a lo que los datos les digan y los datos
han estado diciendo que ahora la
inflación sigue siendo una gran
preocupación y que probablemente estará
con nosotros durante bastante tiempo y
que los precios de la gasolina en
particular han subido mucho más de lo
que se esperaba dentro cheque over
reservan web expecting y por eso creo y
creo que la mayoría de los estrategas lo
creen que lo responsable por parte de la
fed es subir los tipos más agresivamente
a corto plazo para adelantarse a esta
curva inflacionista
bueno y también jorge el bitcoin y otras
cripto monedas continúan a la baja que
se debe esta caída bueno precisamente la
subida de los tipos de interés de la
reserva federal de eeuu y ahora que se
les suma el banco central de europa y el
mercado bajista en wall se le están
poniendo muchísima presión a todo este
mercado del script o moneda mientras la
fed aumenta el costo del dinero para
combatir la inflación los inversores
deciden alejarse y vender estos tipos de
activos los analistas advierten que las
cripto monedas están entrando en una de
sus etapas más oscuras esto ya tiene sus
repercusiones en ese mercado por ejemplo
la plataforma de intercambio de cripto
monedas coin beige anunció que despedirá
a unas 1.100 personas el 18% de su
planilla y advirtió de una posible
recesión o cripto invierno como lo llamó
el bitcoin que es la cripto moneda más
famosa del mercado ha caído por debajo
de los 22 mil dólares y ha perdido un 53
por ciento de su valor en lo que va del
año escuchemos que dicen también los
analistas al respecto
ha mostrado mucha correlación con el
nasdaq y las grandes acciones
tecnológicas durante el último año y
medio más o menos y con la fe subiendo
los tipos durante todo este año y
esperando que siga subiendo los tipos
creo que eso ejerce mucha presión sobre
el bitcoin siendo como es hoy una
especie de almacén de valor muy
incipiente algo así como un oro inmaduro
cambiamos de tema hablemos de áfrica
hablamos específicamente de sudán del
sur en donde millones de personas están
en riesgo por el conflicto interno de
ese país y también por las recientes
inundaciones
santiago para evitar que la gente caiga
ahí en una hambruna el programa mundial
de alimentos de la onu pidió 426
millones de dólares sudan del sur es el
país más joven del mundo vive una
inestabilidad política desde que se
independizó de sudán en 2011 una guerra
civil entre 2003 y 2018 que dejó casi
400.000 muertes y millones de
desplazados el país ahora se prepara
para un cuarto año consecutivo de
inundaciones que podrían obligar a
600.000 personas a abandonar sus hogares
y hablemos ahora de argentina porque la
subida de precios no da tregua el
choripán y la carne carísimo
definitivamente la inflación se aceleró
allí en mayo al 67% 27 puntos
porcentuales por arriba de lo registrado
en abril si vamos al dato mensual en
mayo pasado la inflación fue del 5,1
algo menor a la de abril último pero aún
en un rango elevadísimo los datos del
instituto nacional de estadísticas y
censos muestran que las subidas
registradas en mayo se destacan en la
subida de los precios de la salud un 6,2
por ciento un alza impulsada por el
aumento en las cuotas de la medicina
privada y las del transporte en 6,1 por
ciento pasamos ahora a hablar de para
decirle al presidente ya ayer bolsonaro
celebró la privatización de electrobrás
de qué estamos hablando así es bueno la
empresa es considerada la mayor empresa
de electricidad de américa latina' esta
privatización se hace como parte de un
plan masivo que impulsó el presidente de
jager wilson arias para tratar de
privatizar muchísimas empresas estatales
algo que al finalizar su periodo todavía
no consigue la oferta pública recaudó 16
mil millones de dólares y el ministro de
economía para bloggers calificó
una victoria de la eficiencia del sector
privado en ese país muchas gracias jorge
por esta actualización del mundo de la
economía a continuación el debate aquí
en directo américa
[Música]